winter is coming and there are plenty of
surprises left
the mountain and the viper
this episode this is kind of a big deal
and a lot of stuff again that i'm not
gonna be able to talk about because i
don't do spoilers what can i talk about
well we touch in uh back at moles town
at the wall and we get to touch in with
gilly and a few other characters that
we've seen before and oddly she's not
annoying me when gilly sort of came
around at the end of the third season
and sam really felt responsible for her
i had a feeling like you're gonna bug me
but she's we're getting her in very
small doses that i'm like okay you're
working for me i was afraid it was gonna
become like shea where it started out
interesting but then you just bugged me
please go away thankfully that's not
happening we get some more build up
towards stuff
going bad on the wall i have a feeling
that the the sort of big season set
piece which is usually an episode nine
thing which is our next one is going to
be the assault on castle black because
it's we've been building to this since
the end of the previous season and we
still haven't gotten it and they need to
do it this season because if they don't
then it's gonna become like daenerys
getting over to westeros with her
dragons it can be like how long are you
gonna stall this but it doesn't feel
like they're selling it right now it
feels like they're building very clearly
towards it which makes me very excited
for the next episode but talking more
about this one since i brought up
daenerys let's talk about what's going
on across the narrow sea we get some
really interesting moments with this guy
now i haven't really talked about him
before because there wasn't much to talk
about not that he wasn't good he's
always been great but he's been one of
the kind of stable rocks of the show he
doesn't rock the boat he's there he's
firm you can always count on him well
now they've done something interesting
with him and i've always enjoyed him
largely on the strength of the
performance and now they've they've kind
of taken him in a direction that's like
oh
there's a lot of ways this could go and
i'm not sure where it's going to end up
with for him personally but i like that
that the sort of the rug can get pulled
out into under a character that you
think oh steady as a rock i know this
person's deal oh
well something's going to have to change
where's it going to go dario harris has
been sent off he's bugging me which is
fine we get more time with grey worm
which i'm enjoying and sort of seeing
him
almost try to figure out how to be human
because he's just he's just unsullied
that's what he is that's all he's ever
known and to sort of see him start to
dig within himself to find something
else it's a bit like i'm about to get
sci-fi in my fantasy with this analogy
but it's like when you have a an
automaton or a robotic character trying
to mine some depth and to understand
humanity better it's a bit like that
it's like he's trying to break his
programming is he gonna get there is he
gonna figure it out or is it just gonna
open up a can of worms that really he's
not prepared to deal with i don't know
but i like where it's headed over in the
veil we get some interesting fallout in
terms of where things pick up off of
what happened last time which again
spoiler free can't talk about it sansa
is becoming interesting like
legitimately interesting she has now
finally
got some dimension she seems to finally
for the first time
have an agenda have a plan have
something going on between her ears and
she's not just operating on
moping and trying to survive she's she's
got something else going on i'm not
entirely sure what it is that she's
after and what it is she wants and i
like that but of course the major set
piece of this episode is saved for the
end and that's what goes on at king's
landing now if you've been following the
season at all just on the title of this
episode you know what i'm talking about
even if you haven't seen this episode
yet you know what's been building
towards and it does not disappoint i
have to kind of just leave it at that
but it's just it's well executed and it
builds off of just this pretty much
season long build up towards this moment
that happens that we've been getting
most in small doses for most of the
episodes up to this point so we really
getting they come to a good head at the
end of this episode and then the very
last moment it
ends on makes me go but also
because again seeing the possibilities
where things could go
i know this show could take you the
route norm on any other show it's like
okay that happened now there are these
two options any other show it would
always be this one because if you do the
other thing well then you break the show
well this show is not afraid to break
its mold and completely tear apart what
you think is gone it should be happening
so
i don't know what's gonna happen next
but i cannot wait to find out it's
interesting this episode as a whole
really spends a lot of time giving us
either great little moments with
characters that we don't see a lot of or
adding depth to characters who have been
side characters up to this point oh i do
have to mention one other thing this is
my favorite moment it was so quick
it was with arya and the hound they're
just they're doing going along doing
their things and something happens and
it's not a big event it's not a
life-changing event it doesn't matter
too much in the scope of things but
arya's reaction to it
is gold it's just solid gold in an
already amazing episode it was my
favorite moment by far and i just had to
mention that so let me ask you this i
mentioned sansa and grey worm and a few
other characters who were either
one-dimensional or bored me that are
starting to gain depth who was a
character on the show for you that for a
while you're like i'm not interested but
then something happened something was
done something that was added that made
you interested in them what what is that
character for you drop something down in
the comments and let's talk about it
until next time this council is
adjourned